[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voulez vous qu'on fasse je veux qu'on
soit sincère et qu'un homme d'honneur on
ne lâche aucun mot qui ne partent du
coeur mais quand on est du monde il faut
bien que l'on rende quelques d'or civile
lusage demande
non
excusez moi du coup j'ai un trou là
c'est là il faut concevoir qu'on
commence parce que
offrait aussi recommencerai tout le
monde sera lost aux deux pilotes
moi je suis un adulte avec année les
enfants ont peur donc c'est une
catastrophe qui vient sublime on atteint
du très beau par la catastrophe
alors je dis
y avait peut-être oui ça se dirait comme
ça à l'ancienne
de toute façon on l'aurait enlevée c'est
vraiment quelqu'un d'exceptionnel j'ai
très heureux d'être là d'être avec ta
famille avec tes amis voilà c'est merci
des deux côtés ce qui est incroyable
arrêt ce qu'on sait qu'il y aura des
conneries enfin les choses on va chialer
mondiaux à pascal est bon mon père jeudi
à 90% il est là il a 90 ans il vient pas
là il y aura pas les prochaines
jeanine 80 ans
en un peu moins de 40 ans elle a
transformé le café du coin en une
adresse incontournable
on la surnomme ici la mer la pipe donc
il est vrai qu'au bout d'un fil à plomb
dans la tête est pas question il faut
tempérer ces mots 14 c'est qu'est ce que
c'est alors on peut considérer ça un peu
comme une amulette est censé apporter à
la fertilité
dans ce petit livre de 130 pages
les femmes ont plus de devoirs que de
droits
comme par exemple l'interdiction de
mettre son mari en colère
de se refuser à son époux ou encore de
demander le divorce et ça ça marche bien
en ce moment donc je vous emmerde tout
le plancher et franchement c'est un
grand classique faut savoir que ça
s'arrangera le monde courant de ce qui
se passe en france et que c'est trop
difficile
les taches sur pantalon c'est bon
[Musique]
vous venez d'en avoir une phrase de cinq
ans qui meurent ben c'est pas parce que
la vie est belle et grande qu'il faut se
comporter comme elle
vous à 8h j'étais à la la j'ai été c'est
ma grande déception parce que j'ai fait
mes trois jours et où j'étais j'étais
parti pour et comme j'avais des
problèmes de genoux catastrophe si oui
j'ai la gdd 2 ça va mieux ah oui oui ça
va mais je veux je me protège mes
cuisses
[Applaudissements]
avant les gens n'aillent mais pas assez
aujourd'hui on sent bien qu'on ne peut
plus continuer aux petits égoïsmes voilà
et je trouve ça formidable vous
racontant des anecdotes et ses
généreuses lancé vous vous lancez vous
aurez la porte et vous partez sans fil
et vous tombez vous vous levez vous êtes
couvert de sang vous êtes en morceaux
vous vous relevez c'est une image qui
n'aurait jamais dû se retrouver sur un
marché d'oeuvres numériques aux côtés
des productions de damian hirst et
d'autres artistes cette étrange image
celle d'une radio d'un avant bras dans
lequel s'est logé une balle de
kalachnikov le vendeur ce chirurgien de
la main le professeur emmanuel masmejean
dans l' annonce en anglais il précise
que le bras est celui d'une jeune femme
blessée au bataclan et qui a perdu son
compagnon dans l' attaque du 13 novembre
[Applaudissements]
valeur de l'oeuvre selon mediapart qui a
révélé la sphère de 1776 dollars soit
2400 46 euros une bêtise reconnaît le
professeur nous avons pu lui parler il
se défend de toute intention mercantile
je trouve que cette radio a une grande
valeur historique en postant cette image
j'ai voulu faire une sorte d'essai c'est
maladroit si vous trouvez que c'est une
erreur je les accepte ici on propose des
poupées qui ont toutes le même point
commun elles n'ont pas de visage les
yeux la bouche et le nez ne sont pas
dessinées
[Musique]
donner parce que j'avais jamais vu ça
c'est embêtant lidl
oui oui et pourquoi ils n'ont pas dit
non pas d'abord ils n'ont pas lieu parce
que normalement c'est uniquement par an
on ne fera pas du temps ils vous avaient
fait remarquer en fait moi je j'essaye
de définir une politique étrangère pour
la france mais 30 great games ne dit
rien en français
moi pour moi la france est toujours
grande vous savez donc on n'a pas besoin
d'être guen
je pense qu'elle pose surtout il faut
qu'elle retrouve une certaine
indépendance et une certaine idée
d'elle-même je vais vous faire
apparaître un mot qui est à la mode je
voulais savoir ce que l'académicienne en
pensée ultra crépy d'ariane isme
comportement consistant à donner son
avis sur des sujets à propos desquels on
n'a pas de compétence crédible ou
démontrer qu'est ce que vous en pensez
de ce mot il peut rentrer dans la langue
française cette idée que finalement tout
le monde intervient dans tous les débats
alors que finalement on n'a pas grand
chose à dire je pense que ça c'est la
tragédie vous êtes déjà monté sur le
tour non jamais je me mets non je n'ai
jamais je la vois quand je viens à paris
je la tue la voix de loin je la vois sur
instagram mais je sais pas pu monter ses
des années d'attentes non comment ça se
passe et c'est d'ailleurs très liés à
l'internet et oiseaux sociaux c'est à
dire que ça a des conséquences très
graves d'abord tout le monde intervient
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie de la parole
c'est ailleurs ne sais pas ce qui est
juste qui n'est pas juste ça n'a pas
d'importance moi si je vous entends lava
est-ce que vous l'apprenez non parce que
ça parle de convictions religieuses pour
ma culture ont des convictions
religieuses des femmes mais j'essaie
mais oralement ça c'est une marque de
respect si je vous respecte tellement
que je vous que je préfère au pas vous
serrer la main parce que nous les femmes
on les considère comme des reines
si vous étiez opposé
intégré on pourrait poser je vais vous
répondre j'ai cru que j'avais été
effectivement pendant deux ans et demi
j'ai pris mes règles et donc j'ai cru
que j'étais ménopausées à zhouqu et
bunge et je fais ce qu à cette époque je
vivais avec un homme je me suis séparé
de cet homme là et mes règles sont
revenus ouais mais bon moral et là j'ai
fait j'ai crié j'étais aux toilettes
saisit pas j'avais alors on n'a pas la
double vasque mais on a une surprise
juste en dessous c'est à dire ben je
t'en prie ouvre la petite porte
oui pour nous aurons le lave n'a tenu
qu'à moi vous savez mais là on rigole ça
je suis très ancienne moi j'adore les
vies des gens comme ba dee dont le mât
tout était propre rôle norbert sans moi
un petit peu cette petite odeur à tuchan
pas à briscoe les patrons comme ça c'est
fraises vous c'est bon c'est quoi comme
r&b coup tu sais lire de montcuq
rigole non je parle de montcuq on va
dans la ville de montcuq effectivement
c'est rigolo à je ne sais pas dire